[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
améliorer le recyclage des plastiques
selon l'OCDE en 2019 seul 15% des
déchets plastiques étaient collectés au
niveau mondial et 9% recyclés pourtant
l'enjeu écologique du recyclage des
plastiques et majeurs celui-ci est censé
limiter les émissions de CO2 et
économiser de l'énergie
partant de ce constat le député Philippe
bolo et la sénatrice en gel Préville on
rédigé une note scientifique au nom de
l'OPEX sur le recyclage des plastiques
il propose plusieurs solutions pour un
recyclage efficace dans une perspective
de réduction globale de la consommation
de plastique
l'OPEX relève d'abord que la réalité du
recyclage des plastiques reste très
éloignés d'une économie circulaire
les flux de déchets plastiques sont
globalement peu recyclés en France le
processus de recyclage s'accompagne
ainsi de plus de 36% de pertes le taux
d'incorporation de plastique recyclé
poste consommation est très faible par
exemple les emballages qui représentent
39,1% des plastiques consommés en Europe
ne contiennent que 8,5% de plastique
recyclés en dépit de plusieurs efforts
entreprises l'OPEX souligne que le
recyclage effectif des plastiques se
heurte à plusieurs obstacles le premier
est d'ordre technique
les auteurs de la note évoquent la non
recyclabilité de certains plastiques
l'impossibilité de mélanger des
thermoplastiques ayant des
caractéristiques différentes ou encore
la dégradation des propriétés des
plastiques lors de leur utilisation le
second obstacle est économique le prix
des plastiques vierges n'est pas
suffisamment élevé pour inciter à
l'utilisation de la matière recyclée
parallèlement la disponibilité et la
qualité des gisements de plastique
recyclables ainsi que l'existence
d'usines de recyclage en nombre
suffisants restent des enjeux
structurels majeurs pour le
développement du recyclage
l'OPEX observe en outre que le recyclage
progresse moins vite que la production
de plastique
conséquence d'ici 2060 la production
mondiale de déchets plastiques devrait
tripler pour atteindre 1041 millions de
tonnes le recyclage représentera alors
une part encore plus faible de la
gestion de ses déchets environ 15% des
déchets plastiques risquent alors d'être
mal gérés ce qui pourrait entraîner un
doublement des fuites de déchets
plastiques dans l'environnement et un
triplement de l'accumulation de
plastique dans les milieux aquatiques
pour faire face à cette menace
écologique imminente l'opext recommande
de mobiliser plusieurs leviers visant à
améliorer les taux de recyclage et
favoriser le recyclage de haute qualité
l'Office Parlementaire fait valoir que
le recyclage ne peut pas à lui seul
garantir la mise en place d'une économie
circulaire des plastiques ni même
permettre à l'industrie plastique
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 c'est pourquoi il recommande avant
tout d'inscrire le recyclage dans une
stratégie globale de réduction de la
production de plastique
l'OPEX t'encourage par ailleurs à
améliorer la recyclabilité des
plastiques à travers la prise en compte
de leur recyclage de leur conception en
rendant par exemple la mise sur le
marché de produits non recyclables
réellement dissuasive
l'Office plaide pour que la priorité
soit donnée au recyclage mécanique face
au recyclage chimique dans les appels
d'offres
en effet selon l'OPEX un tri et une
préparation de qualité des matières à
recycler permettent très souvent un
recyclage mécanique en boucle fermée à
des coûts élevés et avec un bilan
environnemental plus favorable qu'avec
le recyclage chimique
l'opexte recommande enfin d'étendre les
obligations d'incorporation de matière
plastique recyclée à tous les secteurs
d'activité et d'introduire des pénalités
pour non atteinte des obligations de
contenu recyclés
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]